so Chuck here's a topic I don't think we
talk enough about Dimensions dementia
huh no
no you may have heard that we live in
three dimensions and time is a fourth
dimension okay and evidence that it
really
matters is even if you don't know it
explicitly you know it implicitly that
time really matters because I can say to
you Chuck I'll meet you tomorrow at
Starbucks right and what's your reply to
me I'll be there all day waiting man
because I got nothing to do I got
nothing to do so I'll just be in
Starbucks I'll start off in the morning
with some breakfast maybe a little
muffin and then I'll just stay there
until you get there okay sorry I'll meet
you at Starbucks at 12 noon okay oh
thanks thanks thanks appreciate that I
gave you a location in space and you had
to wait until I gave you a location in
time time and that intersection of space
and time is called your world line wa
love it it's called A World line World
line so for our world lines to intersect
we have to be at the same place at the
same time see now fellas if you're smart
and you're single you will hold this one
in the back put it away in your back
pocket okay mean girl I just need you as
a part of my world line you know this
rap rap lines from from relativity right
exactly okay and let's reverse that I'll
say Chuck I'll meet you tomorrow at noon
North America good for you thank you
Earth yeah is that all right yeah so we
know intuitively you need both the time
and the space coordinates conjoined in
order to actually meet absurd variance
on that would be you cross the street
and 10 minutes later a truck barrels
through in that same location right so
you were in the same location
as the
truck but not at the same time you
wouldn't say oh man I almost died today
you wouldn't because your world lines
missed each other right and you can do
that another way you exist at the same
time as the truck but you know we're
near each other in location right so
what made zoom and other video
conferencing so useful during covid is
that you only had to be at the same time
right you didn't have to be at the same
place so you take away one of the
components of the world lines right and
then many more people can participate
but you are converging at the same place
virtually or digitally
so uh okay well your image is on I mean
I have my image of you on my computer
but it's not you th this is so let's
keep talking about Dimensions ready so
we have one dimension which is just a
line the measure of the line is the
length there's no other measurement you
can make of it that has any meaning
right right it does not have a width now
you can add another
dimension they call that X we add a y
mhm and now you have a surface a plane a
plane and that has two Dimensions X and
Y okay so you can make a square out of
that couldn't
yeah two dimensional
beings who live in that surface to
everyone else in that surface they only
have an Outer Perimeter right you can't
see inside their bodies they're all
inside the flat plane they inside the
flat all they can see all you see is the
edge of them right the edge so medical
surgery in a two-dimensional Universe
they'd have to cut you open part you and
and then reach in and do what they need
to come out and then Stitch you up again
okay right if we live in three
dimensions you get to look down on that
flat world and see all the inner guts of
every living creature in that Universe
mhm because there is no
boundry above and below it's only within
the plane itself you can see the heart
beating you can see the spleen the liver
the pancreas the lungs you can see it
all in fact if you wanted to be a
surgeon for that world you could go in
cut out the appendix if they needed
appendectomy and never have to cut
through their outer
boundary you'd be like magically going
into their body dimensional surgery
dimensional surgery they would have no
access or even a way awareness that that
was even possible but you do right and
you can go in and rectify that so now we
are in three dimensions we reveal our
skin in all directions to the other
people right so our skin is the boundary
between our innards and a medical
doctor if they want to get inside you
they got to cut you open right a four
dimensional
creature can just look inside our bodies
oh I feel violated
I know oh I hope no one's watching right
now God anyone from the fourth spatial
Dimension has full access to your entire
body's inard oh they could pull stuff
out put stuff in operate whatever we are
the game Operation to anybody in the
fourth
dimension what I'm saying is if you had
what you beautifully refer to as
dimensional surgery you would be able to
operate without ever cutting someone
open provided you come from a higher
dimension in word right and it is
completely analogous to be a
four-dimensional surgeon operating on us
without cutting US Open to be we as
threedimensional
surgeons operating on two-dimensional
creatures because you could just see all
their organs just sitting there now we
can move forward and back left and right
up and down
okay those are the three spatial
Dimensions but the time Dimension you
don't have access to the past or the
future we are
prisoners of the
present forever transitioning between
our inaccessible past and our unknowable
future but let's think this through how
would you imprison a two-dimensional
creature draw a line what kind of line a
square a square just draw a square
that's its prison cell yeah but we say
wait just step up out of it and then you
escape good to go I don't know what
you're talking about I'm fully locked in
fully locked in how do we put us in a
Cell we have six walls right a ceiling
floor four walls around us right we
think we are completely contained within
it a higher dimensional creature just
step out and then step back in and
you're outside the cell we said I don't
know what you're talking about right
wait a minute I said a four-dimensional
creature if if we had access to the
fourth dimension which for us is what
time time but wait we're prisoners of
time so suppose we weren't prisoners of
time suppose you could move through time
the way we move through
space could you then escape the prison
yeah just move to a time when I'm not in
prison
exactly just say let me get out of these
six walls here you just go back to a
time before you got put in a prison or
go to the Future where you would let go
from the prison right each of those
counts as Escaping The Prison without
ever breaking down the wall right so
time can serve that same
role if you had access to the past and
to the Future that's pretty cool man of
course we go higher this fifth
Dimensions sixth Dimensions this sort of
thing and uh mathematically you can
calculate what all the properties are
and it's fascinating to watch another
quick one you ready go ahead Nots in
strings only exist in three
dimensions
okay in other words in a fourth
dimension you hand them a knot in the
fourth dimension say wait just just pull
the ends and it unravels itself that's
the same thing as we three-dimensional
people looking at two-dimensional people
and they have a string that just has
this Loop in it one Loop right and they
say how do I untie this I can't untie
say dude pick up the two ends and
stretch they can't do that right they
can't do that so knots are different
things in higher Dimensions the way to
do it is you have to make a knot out of
a two-dimensional ribbon and there ways
to do that I think and rather than just
out of a string so a lot of interesting
things change and are mindboggling for
ascending to a higher Dimension sweet
one last quick thing mhm why does anyone
want a flying car so you can get up and
over traffic so you only really think
about flying cars in cities where you're
like plugged with traffic and what a
flying car gets you is another dimension
of travel true you no long stuck in a
one lane road cuz that's bad all right
but even if you go two dimensions and
you have multiple Lanes that's now
you're in a plane that can get cloggy
too right so get a third dimension is
wide open but wait a minute that means
we already have flying
cars it's called the
subway oh instead of being in the air
it's underground bypassing the traffic
you're in it still invoked the third
dimension but also it means
overpasses where the freeway goes right
through and the overpass goes over
that's a flying car right there you
invoked another dimension you have a
very low bar for what's
called just say it so I think that's all
the time we have and in another
dimension we would have all the time in
the world all right Neil degrass Tyson
here as always keep looking
[Music]
out